well meantime sunrise hospital says its  vaccine clinic is up and running in full  swing  their first vaccines also arrived about  six o'clock this morning  front line health care workers were  given the shots shortly after to a  round of applause chief medical officer  dr steven murtaz says people are still  a little waffling a little bit about  whether or not to get the shot but he  expects them to eventually get  vaccinated  they were excited early on now they're  not but what we suspect we're still  going to hit that 60 to 80 percent mark  and i think some people just don't want  to be that first individual  but you know they're watching closely  and i think they're excited and they'll  be  signing up tomorrow and the next day  meantime sunrise is not  requiring employees to get the vaccine  it is going to be an  optional choice